foreign
fam welcome to part two of our episode
on thriving or burnout and mentoring
pasturing service and vocation we had a
great episode last week with Dr
Christine fund this week we're joined by
Dr David Ireland we're going to continue
and extend that conversation also
thinking about aspects of leadership as
well so just by way of introduction I
want to let you all know a little bit
about Dr Ireland he is the founder and
Lead pastor of Christ Church which is a
10 000 member multi-site congregation in
North Jersey it has over 70
nationalities represented in that
congregation and he is someone who has a
lot of leadership experience as well he
also is someone who is important in the
world of diversity Equity inclusion he's
been a diversity consultant to the NBA
he's also LED Chapel Services for the
New York Giants the New York Jets and
also the U.S pentagon it's also a
prolific author of over 25 books so
someone who has had a lot of influence
in a lot of different spheres he also
holds a range of different degrees so he
has graduate degrees in Engineering also
in Theology and organizational
leadership and also in Social Innovation
so I think you're really going to enjoy
the conversation that we had again kind
of continuing this theme of thinking
about thriving or burnout practical ways
that we can do that and ways we can also
create cultures and environments that
facilitate those times of productivity
and sacred rhythms of rest as well
just want to remind you all as well that
I do have a new newsletter so if you
want to check that out you can find it
on substack you can read it there you
can subscribe you can also go straight
to the URL so nii
addy.substack
s-u-b-s-t-a-c-k.com and you can find
that newsletter lots of different topics
I'm talking about there about my journey
and also kind of amplifying and going
into more depth about some of these
podcast conversations as well so again
really glad that you all are here do
also want to take a time to acknowledge
the timing of this episode release as
well so this episode is coming out on
February 1st so the start of Black
History Month something that's very
important obviously for us in this
country but unfortunately also comes on
the heels what has been a very difficult
week and a very difficult few weeks with
everything that's been going on around
the conversation of the tragic and
unfortunate killing of Tyree Nichols
again another black man killed at the
hands of police and this of course is
coming on the heels of ongoing tragedy
these even as we took time to pause with
everything that happened in California
with the shootings again which should
have been at a time of Celebration with
the Lunar New Year but again we see just
the ugliness of these incidents that
continue to happen and so I did want to
take time to acknowledge that there are
a range of emotions that I've been
feeling that many of you have been
feeling as well as they always are
during these times brief and mourning
the anger the frustration sometimes
feelings of hopelessness and so I did
want to just take time to pause and
acknowledge that and also to remind all
of you as listeners just to give
yourself time to process and to support
one another as well even in this episode
as we're thinking about things like
thriving and burnout to also acknowledge
that this Trauma from seeing these
images the vicarious Trauma from
thinking about these things that is real
many people and experts have talked
about that and there may be things that
you feel at different points in time
that hit you so to give yourself time to
pause to know that it can also affect
how you navigate through through the day
and as we think about this aspect of
thriving or burnout knowing that can
also lead to places where you're feeling
stretched in I know for me I've had to
be very intentional about having those
times of reflection but then just also
having times to to step away from going
too deep into that many psychologists
have suggested not to watch that video
and just to imprint that can leave on
you that's a personal decision you all
have to make but I also just want to
extend just my sympathies to to the
family members to to the friends to the
entire community and for what a lot of
us are navigating through obviously it
has been set in many places you should
still be here that is just the reality
that's not something that we can change
but we can honor his life and hopefully
we will get to a place of having true
change so again obviously a somber
moment but I did want to take time and
acknowledge that as well
um so with that I hope you all are doing
the best as you can to take care of
yourselves to practice that self-care to
be in support to be in community of one
another and I hope that as you listen to
this episode that even as you're
thinking about some of those things that
you'll be able to think about that and
as well and know that we are all here
for each other um even in the way that
we had this episode even though it was
recorded before these police videos were
released to know that the tone of that
also is in that state of support and how
we can support each other as a community
so with that I hope that you all get a
lot out of this episode I think you're
really going to be encouraged by it and
there's a lot that Dr Ireland share that
will really be beneficial and uplifting
for all of us so enjoy
well it's my pleasure again to be able
to host this conversation it's been a
while since we've had consistent
episodes but I'm really excited that we
are moving into that in 2023 and this is
a topic that we'll be talking about
today that a lot of you have been asking
about in terms of burnout something that
is definitely relevant that a lot of us
experience maybe in the midst of or
maybe on the verge of or coming out of
so again I think this is just going to
be a wonderful conversation part two in
a sense as we already have talked with
Chris fund and really just excited to be
able to host Dr David Ireland on the
Addie Hour podcast thank you so much for
being here
my pleasure thank you so much Dr Eddie
of course Joy yeah
and I know we were talking a little bit
offline before we started the recording
but I wanted to give you all just an
introduction to Dr Island I know you've
heard the intro that I gave but just to
give you a sense of who he is because so
many things that he is about really are
embedded in our podcast conversation too
many things for us to cut to talk about
in the one conversation today but also
just want to give you all a sense of who
he is and even as you heard from Dr fund
knowing that she was also excited about
this dialogue today so Dr Anna if you
could just give us a little bit about
your journey into Ministry I guess going
all the way as far back as you want to
go but maybe starting from your college
days uh to here and how you've gotten to
this place well my pleasure I actually
was a an atheist I thought people I was
a scientific atheist you know from the
teenage years and I started college at
16 and I did my first degree in
engineering mechanical engineering and
then when I graduated at 20 and I went
into graduate school did a mechanic did
a master's in civil engineering so I
worked in that profession but at the age
of 20 I had this life transforming
experience or series of experiences and
that's where I became then you know a
follower of Jesus Christ you know I
didn't even realize I was praying I just
got to the in my the end of my rope so
to speak and after graduating I started
thinking what's there must be more to
life than making a lot of money marrying
a pretty wife you know having the nice
house even though I had none of those
things
and I said I remember sitting on the
edge of my dormitory bed and I said God
if you're real change me and and he
changed me and I my Outlook my world
view is changed the way I thought about
myself was changed and then I started to
build this relationship with Jesus
Christ and I practiced engineering for
about six years you know after graduate
school you know and uh and then I
transitioned into Ministry went to
Seminary then went on did a PhD then did
lots of post-doctoral work I'm a school
guy
so yeah so that's who I was I did my
last uh degree at postgraduate degree at
the University of Cambridge in England
you know in Social Innovation you know
and so you know I'm always learning and
trying to grow right well you're you're
in good company being a school guy and I
know that a lot of our listeners will be
able to relate to that as well but even
those who maybe haven't been lifelong
people in our education spaces who are
just continuing to learn in so many
different ways so appreciate you sharing
that story as well
um and just to unpack a little bit I
know we were talking about your most
recent degree but if you could tell our
listeners about some of the work that
you've done
um over the years in terms of what you
talked about terms of cultural
competency because a lot of those things
are also near and dear to what we've
talked about on this podcast
the research interest has always been
diversity more more particularly
building multi-racial organizations and
so when I did my dissertation uh years
ago 20 years ago it was on the black
white relationship in large multiracial
churches in America to understand that
this most recent dissertation was on how
do you help white leaders
enjoy developing a lifestyle of
Intercultural competence I mean how do
you because right now a lot of white
males particularly feel demonized when
it comes to having conversations about
diversity Equity inclusion and so yeah I
I have then worked on that space and so
I do Consulting for you know some of the
major corporations in addition to being
a pastor I I provide I'm a pastor of a
church about 10 000 people and has 75 or
I should say 70 different nationalities
and so I provide leadership to Asians
whites Native Americans blacks Latinos
you know you know so the whole Spectrum
so to speak and so I'm honored to do
that and and I say that and I give that
information because the racially diverse
Church in America is a very rare animal
and for someone then to be of color
leading a racially diverse church that's
even you know that's like an Elvis
sighting so to speak
yeah I mean it represents less than one
percent so to speak you know
statistically so it's very rare but it's
an intentional process you don't bring
about diversity by happenstance there's
there's intentionality this planning and
there's a lot of heart change and
introspection those kinds of searching
and probative investigative things so
you'll be able to understand
you know so it's almost even like when I
deal with preaching I've gone through
where you have individuals who listen to
your sermons be it black white asian
atheist agnostics and and they give
feedback how am I being interpreted how
am I coming across what are you hearing
in other words am I speaking
cross-culturally am I speaking to
everybody and unless we go through that
type of you know reflection and you know
I should say that exercise we don't know
how we're coming across yeah we don't
know how we're being interpreted yeah I
appreciate putting that all in context
and I mean I 100 agree in terms of the
Rarity of what you're doing as a black
male leader as well and how that's not
often the case but it's really
refreshing to hear also how much you are
a learner and a listener even as you
listen to that feedback and I would
imagine that's that's also facilitated
your Effectiveness over the years in
just the different spaces that God has
placed you in absolutely in fact I've
had the opportunity to speak in some 75
countries one of the countries I
remember going to I was in Zambia so you
that the South Central African country
that I'll be able to be a winner when I
get there so to speak it and my and I'm
in Lusaka the capital and so this is a
group of about 8 000 leaders that were
there and so when I started after my
first talk I can feel there was this gap
between me and them and so I asked the
host I said am I correct in my
perception that there's this wall
between us between me and the and and
the leaders that are there and he said
you're correct
and I said why is that there I've not I
don't know them I have not done anything
to them and they said this to me so I'll
never forget he said that because you're
an American and they think that you're
going to hurt them
so I had to in order to get it to to
break that wall down even though we
shared the same race different
nationality different culture but we had
the same racial makeup both being black
you know the diff the Gap was oh I
should say in order for me to be
successful in that conversation and that
series of conference meetings I had to
become more vulnerable so the more I was
able to display a common Humanity that's
when they dropped their guards because
they've put they put me beforehand in
the category that says you're an
American and Americans will think that
they think they're better than us and we
are quote unquote poor Africans and so
we don't want to be hurt again and so
they had that predisposition before I
even opened my mouth right and so I had
to help get around that but this this
similar things happen no matter what
country you're in you find that you have
to have those conversations and to your
point to be a learner I have to ask
people
how am I being interpreted what am I
what how am I coming across and I must
then be willing to shift and pivot
quickly so I can be engaging with that
particular audience
I'll really appreciate that story and
you're you're just your openness to that
as well and I think that speaks volumes
just to even the
assumptions that we carry into places
um regardless of whether we intend to or
not both from the perspective of those
who are listening and from you coming
into that place and not even expecting
that so I think that's really yeah
really powerful but you know as we've
been talking and you've been sharing
again about all these different things
that you do except for which again tie
into the uh podcast episodes I'm trying
not to go too far astray and bring us
back to the topic at hand as well but
just thought it would be helpful for our
listeners to kind of have that context
um but it's funny you know as I was
reading your bio and thinking about all
the different things that you're doing
some of what you're sharing there and
this topic about burnout my mind
immediately went to a place of how is
this person not spread too thin and all
the things that they do so I wonder if
you could also just share with our
listeners as well
um your just your your structure as it
were in terms of how you lead and then
also I know we'll get into this this
topic of burnout but what your
experience has been either from your own
personal experience or from those that
you lead on this topic of burnout
and I appreciate the question and I'll
be very candid with you that I would
look back maybe 20 years ago I yeah I
only knew one speed I just
you know it's like that's how I I lived
I was just working you know I tell
people My love language is productivity
the more you produce the more I feel
about that I don't need a hug I just
need I just it's like almost like that
line on the Amazon website where's my
stuff
yeah I just want my stuff yeah and so
but over the years the last 20 years
I've had to put in place what I call
sacred rhythms so for me you know one of
the things I have to do since I'm the
public speaker I'll speak more no more
than four weeks in a row as a pastor and
then take two weeks off and I'm saying
that because it was a study that was
done years ago when the University of
Texas that said one hour of public
speaking is equal to eight hours of
manual labor so your body actually goes
through the physical shock like I was
doing a construction worker's job
because it's very emptying very draining
when you do that week after week after
week after a while you can become a
basket case so thankfully I was able to
then to create the sacred rhythms you
have to have effective teams so I took
time I took a step back and started to
train people individuals that were very
competent they had gifts skills it took
time to do that and you know I remember
as the Zambian proverb that says when
you run alone you run fast
but when you run together you run far
I had been in the first 20 years of
ministry running fast
now I run together and so I slowed down
put in place gifted leaders trained them
took the time to train them the time to
to coach them and to make sure and
Mentor them so that I can be able to
have these sacred rhythms and then put
that and help put that pla that
structure in place for themselves so
they won't experience burnout I yeah
that's really powerful in a lot of ways
and actually makes me think about some
of the topics that Chris fund was
talking about as well but then even as
I'm listening to you talk I'm also just
thinking that some people may be hearing
this and thinking well I don't have I
don't have a space to actually slow down
and take that time or even when we were
talking about the burnout conversation
as well one of the things that she
brought up was just you know when people
are mentoring so many different students
or training others feeling the guilt or
feeling like there isn't enough room to
actually slow down to get to that place
so what would you say to someone like
that who's feeling that tension in a
very acute kind of way
and I realized I have a certain
privilege because you know I'm the the
lead guy so to speak in my organization
so I really set my schedule but I would
say to that person in a very empathetic
way to say the things that can
contribute to recharging for example
getting away getting away could be you
know it's changing space that means for
example Beauty recharges the heart it's
going into places where you feel
energized and you know it's whether it's
going to a museum whether it's going to
even the mall and you don't have to shop
and lose money in order to get recharged
but it's just it's it's it's beauty that
recharges you not only getting away but
getting together socialize the social
aspect friends that you know it's having
conversations and it doesn't have to be
any technical conversations it's just
how are you doing it's talking it's just
talking there's some people that are I'm
very close with when we get together and
talk it's as if everybody else in the
room is is invisible able because we're
so absorbed in the conversation that and
and the conversation again may not be
technical or heady but it's just the
company so I would encourage individuals
that say look I can't I can't take time
off but you can take respites you can't
take you know a couple hours break you
can do certain things so I would say you
get away you get together and and you
get alone you know the place of being
alone is a very important place because
you know it's it recharges you when
you're able to think process your
feelings get in touch with yourself ask
yourself questions like who Am I who am
I becoming who do I want to be and when
you ask those kinds of pensive
reflective questions in this quiet space
you know it's amazing
yeah that's really well said and I'm
sure that listeners will be able to take
that and enjoy that as well and in a
sense I don't know if this is the case
for you but it made me think in the
sense about the juxta's position to the
what you talked about earlier just going
going going I know for me if I'm in that
mode talking to others is often not time
to reflect and to pause and sometimes I
mean I've had this experience with my
students as well that place feels
productive to them but it actually
becomes very inefficient because they're
going so hard they don't actually think
through things as well as they could and
the pausing actually creates more space
and increases the productivity of
whatever work they may be involved in as
well so I think that's really really
important absolutely in fact Henry
Newman the gifted author and theologian
said that
a person without a quiet space a lonely
place it's dangerous so so we all need
to have that that those Quiet Moments
will reflect and and even if it again is
half an hour over the course of a day
you just need to be able to sit you
could have you know quiet music or
sometimes no music and just sit there
and just enjoy the sacredness of of of
The Quiet space it recharges you in fact
a sign of burnout is when there are more
mistakes
and because you're busy all the time so
you're not as thoughtful not as
reflective another sign is a lack of
creativity so it's almost like the soul
has a dashboard and when you're going
through burnout some things increases
other things decrease those are signs
it's almost like when you're looking at
the dashboard of your car if you're
driving and the things that decrease you
see the fuel level decreases the heat
increases of the engine and if you're
not careful you know when we're not
looking at the dashboard of our souls
and being in touch with ourselves we
don't know where that version burned out
and so when you find someone just go off
the rails you think it just happened no
it didn't just happen yeah it was it was
over a period of time and they just
weren't monitoring the dashboard of
their souls looking at the things that
were increasing the things that are
decreasing and so yeah so some of the
things that that increase is cynicism
but when someone's at the verge of
burnout they're more sarcastic they're
you know they're jaded they have this
sense of humanness biting and and it may
sound witty and clever
but it's dangerous and what's even more
dangerous is that oftentimes the cynic
is accurate but the but the cynicism is
very destructive and so it's a sign
though the increase cynicism is a sign
that you're on the verge of burnout you
know and so I want to you know the
listeners to be very cautious of that
it's not being witty per se it it's it
showed me that you're empty you're
getting empty you're becoming empty yeah
that's really important and I'm glad
you're bringing that up as well would
you say that people just making maybe
more of a societal conversation
perspective are we becoming more aware
of that and paying more attention to it
because I can see different ways that
that cynicism may be interpreted or even
rewarded per se because people may still
be able to be quote unquote productive
or effective even if they are against
that place of burnout so what what has
been your observation in that sense in a
technical sense I think that individuals
who know what to look for it's almost
like a person whose experience as a
parent understands when they see you
know someone with a child a young child
and they're just letting them do they're
running letting them run wild they don't
understand what's going to happen 20
years from now and so an experienced
person sees it and understands it an
inexperienced person doesn't a careful
person who cares about the individual
will bring that out to them in a
respectful honoring way someone that
doesn't really doesn't care they just
want to use them and just they'll work
them and almost like drive them to the
ground you know giving my stuff and then
move on and they don't care about the
person so you know but I know that uh
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
did a study in 2020 where they engaged
the queensland's Queensland University
and they did a study to try to find out
the post the impact of of covid and you
know in regards to the the burnout the
mental issues the mental health and they
saw that there's a 28 increase in this
in these social disorders as a result of
you know the pandemic the stressors
depressive disorder anxiety disorder so
depressive disorder shot up globally 28
percent you know anxiety the disorder
increased by 26 globally just because of
the pandemic and and it and not that we
even changed behaviors just the
stressors of living in our society and
so I would say that you know
particularly people that are in
leadership roles have to deal with with
individuals all the time you know they
have to think about the mental health
piece and and give people spaces to
recharge you know you know it's you know
it's so important yeah yeah 100 I agree
and I'd be curious if there are you know
any anecdotes or stories or perspectives
you can share on just if there are ways
that you've actually just tried to
facilitate that because again me being
outside of being in a pastoral Ministry
role but just seeing the conversations
shift especially from as a mental health
Advocate it seems that in the past a lot
of that has been pushed to the side or
not acknowledged in the roles when
people are pastors or ministers and the
expectation just continue to meet
people's needs and meet people's needs
without necessarily being as attentive
to mental their own mental health needs
or burnout and so what has been your
experience in terms of receptivity and
how have you tried to facilitate that as
well of having conversations like this
in a very Frank direct honest way has
been very helpful and so I've made it a
very public issue I've spoken on it tons
of times not only to my staff I have a
staff of about 100 people and and my
leadership team is about 500 leaders and
so I've had to then work with these men
and women from at different stages in
life in their careers and things like
that in order to be able to say let's
put certain things in place and so we'll
put you know specific things in place
such as you know these sacred rhythms I
talk about for those who are part of our
teaching teams we have the sabbatical
the concept of of the sabbatical after
six years of ministry you know they take
three months off and they recharge we
have also the times where we'll put
their names on on the schedule it says
like for me no David Ireland so no di
weekend that means I'm off the grid No
One's Gonna Be able to get a hold of me
and
and even for the staff we the times that
they work from home the times that they
work they're physically there in the
office and we give them an opportunity
to say give us input how are you doing
we we've we created the chaplaincy
program you know so that you know even
for the staff to say okay you go and
meet with you know the chaplains that we
have on staff the mental health
professionals
unpack whatever needs to be unpacked so
that you we want you to be mentally
healthy and so we have that
yeah and then the check-ins periodically
just to say how are you doing what's
going on you know because you know
oftentimes You Don't See
the signs because if if one of the signs
is productivity but there are other
signs yeah a loss of empathy you know
the issue of compassion fatigue you know
where I'm tired of caring I don't I
don't care anymore it's too exhausting
and and if you're it's particular when
you're in a caring profession when
you're tired of caring is this a problem
yeah yeah exactly yeah I mean that's
very encouraging to hear in the way that
you've described it you've built it into
the culture as well
um and and it seems like also leading by
example in your own because you talked
about those rhythms in your own life and
making sure that's baked in for everyone
else are there ways that you've seen
that um perpetuate amongst your staff
and amongst your community just as
you've kind of tried to bake it in yeah
what I've seen is that they've accepted
the limitations and let me know
limitations in the sense that
not everyone has the same capacity
there's some people that can juggle 15
balls at the same time others they can
only juggle too and one's not better
than the other they're just different
and so we have to be aware of that the
same way children I'm not going to
expect a six-year-old to be able to
speak as eloquently as a 15 year old or
you know or the six-year-old to be as
patient as as as as a college student I
I just won't expect that and so I'm not
going to place pressures on them so to
answer your question people have
accepted their limitations accepted
their capacity and accepted the
frequency of what they need I remember
several years ago my wife and I were
hosting a marriage seminar for a group
and
at one point in the seminar my wife
spoke to all the husbands in a separate
room I spoke to all the wives and so
that's always dangerous because
and after the after the presentation
some of the women asked questions one
woman was very vulnerable she said
my husband and I we have two special
needs kids and I find myself
yelling at them so frequently yo how do
I deal with that
and my answer to her it seemed as if I
wasn't even listening to her question I
asked because my answer raised another
question I said to her how often do you
take vacation
and as she paused because she had not
been a frequency of vacation and I said
let's not even talk about a vacation
where you go away for a couple of weeks
how often do you take a respite from
providing the care to your children and
I said to her it's not that you're not a
bad mother you're just a tired mother
and you just and what you need is to
build in these sacred rhythms in your
life and you may need more of that
because your children have special needs
and so it requires a more frequent
respite than someone who may not be
caring for special needs children and I
think it's giving people permission to
say you're a human being and and don't
label yourself in a moralized way when
the answer is the problem is not a moral
problem the problem is a behavioral one
it's in the sense that you just need
respites in your life and it's and
sometimes for us it's philosophical and
and even cultural if you come from a
culture that says look if you take a
break you're lazy and you're you're bad
you know then we need to reframe what uh
the problem really is yeah that's so
powerful so well said it actually
relates directly to even a question that
Dr fund and I were talking through
yesterday in that conversation you know
in terms of mentoring and educating but
also in Ministry the challenge of saying
no to someone in need so in that example
you gave even someone with special needs
children and it seemed like part of it
was I can't say no to them because I
have to be there for them it could keep
to continue so one thing that Chris fund
raised as well was just you know that
tension it was something that she had
been thinking through and wrestling even
as we were preparing for this episode
about with her own Christian life
experience as well and the concept of
Selfless Love and those types of things
and how do we navigate in that space
actually saying no to someone that's in
the versus quote unquote self-care when
that doesn't always fit the narrative
that we are taught about or talked or
taught and talk about so I think the way
you describe that is really helpful I
don't know if there's anything else that
you want to add to that question and I
think I would add to it that it's not
wrong for me to provide careful myself
it's almost like the dialogue that we
hear when we when we get on an airplane
they tell us look first put your own
mask on before you help that person
whether you're a child or an aged parent
to put on their mask so and it seems
almost
contrary to logic but it is logical and
so when I care for myself and and I'm
and it's not about you know me being
egotistical or feeling that more
valuable than the other it's about I
can't be of any value to anyone if I'm
falling apart or if I'm so broken or if
I'm so needy you know it it doesn't work
that way yeah yeah and so it's really
it's it's about planning and so even to
that Mom with the special needs children
it's about planning where you can say
look I'm gonna hire a babysitter I'm
going to get you know my parents to come
and sit for you know a Friday evening so
my husband and I can go out to the
movies or it's a it's about putting some
structure in place that's practical to
have these respite so that you can
function in an emotionally healthy way
it's needed yeah yeah I highly agree
just to push the envelope a little bit
farther because I know again this is
just something that I know people are
wrestling with so even with all those
was good practices there's still
sometimes that feeling of guilt that I'm
still not doing what I should or or
perfectionism or even a mixture of the
two like how so how have you kind of
helped people and maybe it's just
practice in time but really kind of move
from that either for themselves or I
would say even the stigma that comes
because even as we've talked about you
know people in leadership pastors and
ministers having more space for
themselves it seems that when there is a
breakdown it's still so easy for many of
us to get to that place of judgment like
oh well how could they how could they
falter they're supposed to be the model
we're looking up to them if they're if
they're struggling then how are the rest
of us supposed to be able to to make it
through a more quote unquote following
them and I'll say that there are times
when I take breaks I still at times
struggle with a little bit of guilt
saying look I should be doing this so I
should be busy doing that or that thing
is hanging over my head and you know so
I've never completely overcome the idea
of that and I think in some regards it's
always going to be there yeah because
it's just the Human Experience yeah yeah
and and and it's okay that's the point
I'm bringing out I think the tension of
saying the things I can do but yet I
need time to recharge that tension is
going to be there and I think the
tension's healthy because it's saying in
essence that
I want to be responsible and I want to
maintain a lifestyle of being
responsible in all of my areas of of
oversight so to speak but in the same
breath I'm going to make sure I take
care of me and I and I think that's
something that's so important I can't
just Soldier on and think that it's okay
it doesn't work that way yeah yeah well
I think that's so important just not we
can't pretend that the guilt's not there
and to still experience it but to know
that it's still a process that we're
moving through as well I think it's
really helpful and it's a learned it's a
learned experience even Jesus in sacred
scripture tells his disciples after a
busy stint of ministry he says to them
come with me by yourselves to a quiet
place and get some rest you know and so
he's saying to them look you guys don't
just Soldier on even though what you're
doing is so critical and he himself has
that critical leader he's saying look I
need to recharge because if I don't
recharge I'm not going to be effective
or I'm not going to continue being
effective and he was teaching them that
discipline of really safeguarding their
mental health yeah yeah and that's
really well said so as we've been
talking just to Pivot a little bit I'm
also you know I'm wondering a little bit
about Legacy in a sense but then also
thinking about the Next Generation and
one reason that came up you know as
we're talking about the increased rates
of depression increased rates of anxiety
obviously that's been a topic of
conversation for our youth as well so
I'm curious if that's something that
you've thought about that's coming into
play as you've talked about a lot of
these principles or even burnout and how
if that is the case how you've tried to
not translate but try to impart that on
the Next Generation as well I think it's
I'm involved in succession planning I do
Consulting and in that regard as well
with senior leaders you know and and but
to your point I think it's really
helping to create a cultural awareness
and a personal philosophy of leadership
that says take sacred take or establish
and Safeguard sacred rhythms so you're
teaching them they're doing it anyway
but they're doing it under the principle
that may be very quote unquote unhealthy
and so I encourage parents I said look
when your children have been in school
all day
and when they come home don't just
simply say that don't go do your
homework let them take a break let them
recharge and I think that and for some
parents it took a long time to wrap
their minds around that because they
came from a family of origin that says
go do your homework and then you can
relax and I said flip the switch let
them relax put some times constraints on
it and then have them do their homework
so this way they feel emotionally whole
because I think that we're if we're
creating children and even the Next
Generation that are emotionally
unhealthy they won't have longevity and
I think the the proof of a good mental
health is that their sustainability
there's longevity you're not just you're
not doing something quick and then after
five years you're burnt out you know
right there must be some sustainability
to what you do yeah yeah I think that's
really really well said as well um and
even though there's terms of this
burnout conversations that conversation
that you feel like is helpful that
you've been able to have with young
people as well and this are the signs
different or is it similar to what you
mentioned before in terms of some of
that cynicism and lack of empathy
I think both is yeah the the title if
you use the title burnout it drives
people away it's almost
but if I if I use the word
sustainability if I I have to I have to
word Smith it in order to make it
attractional because if I say it for
example how to avoid burnout no one's
coming today to that seminar but if I
say how to be effective for a long time
okay I'm going
so it's almost uh reframing the
statement so it becomes a quote-unquote
sexy and attractive to leaders both
young and old and that's what I found to
be the case so I've had to change titles
having been the recipient of saying I'm
not going to that Workshop I'm going to
the one yeah making it palatable and
attracted to people so exactly I mean
yeah yeah
well I know we already had uh Chris fund
on but I'm curious if there are any uh
people maybe I'll figure out a way to do
this but if there's anything if she was
here if there's any questions you would
have posed to her in terms of the
mentorship piece you know talking
specifically in academic spaces or
training or just any thoughts around
that I think
I'm mentoring as well I think every
space is mentoring because there has to
be succession you have to pass on to
others the things you've learned over
the years and I think I would just
commend her for the the discipline of
saying I have a responsibility to the
Next Generation
they should build on the things that
I've built so to speak and so they stand
on my shoulders so they can go farther
and be able to do more things and so it
does require then for me to look behind
and say let's let's pull them forward I
I remember I I I had this conversation
it was me about maybe 20 or 30 other
people I served on the executive
committee for the Last Crusade of Dr
Billy Graham's Life
The Crusade in 2005 in New York City and
I remember Dr Graham said something
he said this he said
I wish I had made friends that were a
lot younger than me wow it was all my
friends
have died
and so I mean it I mean it's one of
those sometimes you hear something you
write it down other times it's written
on you that was written on me so to you
know to Chris fund and to others other
mentors I would say
being a mentor means that you're making
friends with people that are younger the
Protege younger and experienced younger
in age but this is what one of the
quintessential leaders uh Dr Billy
Graham you know was was remiss about
saying man I wish I would have spent
more time doing that and so it's you
know and I and I think
it's a it's dangerous when we only are
concerned about ourselves and our uh
pushing things forward and our level of
productivity and building quote unquote
our kingdoms and our organizations so
there must be a turning around to the
Next Generation to say I have a
responsibility to help you guys fulfill
your destiny and your and create Legacy
for you so let me spend myself helping
you so so so in other in other words I
have to recharge because I have a
responsibility to the Next Generation
yeah so if I don't maintain my own
mental health then I'm being
irresponsible as a leader um
yeah that's so powerful I mean even
thinking of my own Journey you know as
things have moved over the years that
that tenancing that pulls sometimes to
to shift to continue to Mentor but to
shift the circle as it were to to peers
in order to learn from them things but
at that comment that you mentioned it's
so powerful of what can be missed if
that goes too far and just the power of
that and Chris mentioned that as well
just the privilege of being able to
mentor and impact the Next Generation so
I think that's that's really something
that will definitely sit with me as well
and I'm sure with our listeners I
appreciate that and it still sits with
me also yeah because I have that
responsibility yeah yeah and then I know
Emma keep bringing things up that she
said as well but just to tie them
together just the the
modeling and the example that can come
from that as well so one thing that she
shared about one of the studies that
they had done uh specifically around
burnout was just asking some of those
who are being mentored about their
experiences and some of them you know
this can fit into pastoral care as well
but looking at mentors and thinking that
those individuals never dealt with
things like burnout or some of those
mental health challenges and then those
individuals feeling dissuaded and not
wanting to go into certain professions
because they're saying well if this
person never struggles with burnout this
isn't something I can do so I think I
need to opt and go elsewhere which isn't
is a fallacy in and of itself so I think
it speaks even to all the things that
you talked about before that what you
bait into culture and lead by example
that transparency even as you talked
about your initial experience I believe
it was in Zambia having that
transparency in Baltimore how powerful
that is even in terms of the impact in
the Next Generation
the topic of burnout is such a sensitive
topic that some people it's almost I
have to take a play out of the The
Playbook of individuals that take an
autocratic position saying I have to
impose respites for some people because
they're going to keep running until the
wheels fall off and so after then put it
in place so this is mandatory this is
necessary you have to do this you can't
come to work tomorrow this needs to take
place because you know because they're
not seeing it and or or they're not
accepting their human Frailty and I
think that is a reality also for some
leaders and again it ties into that
whole cultural piece if they came from a
cultural background that says you don't
take time off that's not right yeah
that's wrong and they look at it as a
moral issue ethical issue when it's not
that you know it's it's a lifestyle
issue to say I want sustainability and
there's and I must be able to not only
enjoy the work of my hand the work of my
mind but I must enjoy relationships and
and and make sure I enjoy myself that
I'm healthy yeah yeah now again I just
think that speaks about your
Effectiveness as a leader as well
um you know sometimes more of a delegate
mode sometimes more autocratic and in
that instance I think the autocratic is
so helpful to say this is something that
you need and to lead by that example and
to put into place
um in my own experience I've seen people
in a sense slowly incorporate that and
then come back and say oh okay I
actually realized that I do need this
and to have the benefits of that after
the fact I think is is huge and
tremendous
important that's so important yeah yeah
so I did want to incorporate because we
had some questions from our audience as
well from our listeners and I think
you've actually touched on this pretty
well but just to I'll just make sure
that I State the question as well but
people are asking you know about all
these aspects of either avoiding or kind
of navigating through a burnout
especially when they feel like more and
more responsibilities are being added on
kind of that sense that some people have
that those who are doing good work then
get given more work and I know you've
talked about this before but you know
what would you say to that person who's
either feeling the push because they
have to for instance get promoted or
move up move up the line or there's so
many tasks in front of them and again if
there's anything you want to add just to
that person you're just saying I don't
know how to incorporate this and I think
that what I've seen leaders do is that
they've negotiated responsibilities with
their employers or their supervisors in
other words if their supervisor says
this person is very effective I need to
give them this because I know they'll do
a good job they then the employee then
and has to be vocal in a respectful way
and say Here's what I'm doing now if I
add this on my plate something's going
to give so of these let's say 10 things
that I'm carrying what would you like me
to give up in order to take on this 11th
what would you want me to and put it
back on the leaders you know the
leader's plate so the leader begins to
think about priorities and timelines and
what's reasonable because sometimes
they're not conscious of it because
they're carrying a whole big load
themselves and and I think the
negotiation process is important and
even with the Advent of working from
home what I've seen some leaders do is
the fact that they've said look part of
my resp I will not take any meetings
before 8 A.M because I want to take my
kid to school and nothing's going to get
in the way of that because I it's
necessary for me to sit you know with me
in the car and have those conversations
with my kids and to check in with them
and I don't want to and and they block
out things and so I think that the idea
is to negotiate with your your
supervisors these realities and and let
them know that you're starting to see
signs of burnout your own life and you
don't want that to take place and you
tell them and it's not cost effective to
the company so even if they only
understand economic State the
conversation economical I think that's
really wise and I would say even a step
further one thing that I've noticed and
been blessed is to actually have leaders
sometimes take that initiative so even
stepping into new roles and having
leaders say do you need me to talk to
the next supervisor online to ask them
to remove something from your place so
that you can do this effectively and not
be spread thin so I 100 agree and then
from both sides that's been really
powerful to see as well yeah and and you
feel supported when that happens yeah
and it and it makes you enjoy the
workplace and the workplace satisfaction
increases because you see that people
are genuinely concerned about you and
your well-being and not just about the
productivity or your talent so to speak
yeah yeah and again it seems to just
speak to the culture as well of the
environment or the institution and
really valuing people so that's so true
yeah
well you shared a lot of just practical
information that's been really useful
and perspectives as well but I'm curious
are there any uh Last Words you'd really
want to share with the listeners to
encourage again many who are listening
who are in service roles or even in
teams and trying to
um you know meet the needs of those in
their team and just all these different
topics anything you want to leave them
with I would just encourage them to look
at the dashboard of their soul and to
see where they are and check on your
dashboard often is there an increase of
cynicism that's bad is if there's a
decrease of creativity that's bad
if there's an increase of empathy that's
good a decrease of productivity that's
bad so you look at some of the things on
the dashboard of your life and it'll
help you see where you are and when you
see things that are signs that are
indicated to say wait a second that's
not good take some time for yourself and
recharge it's really well said really
well said I know that people are going
to listen to this episode more than once
just to soak in all the things that you
and Chris fund have mentioned and it's
been it's been a pleasure to see the
overlap and for both of you just to see
the ways that you're really
incorporating this into who you are and
how you're leading and how you're
modeling and how you're also encouraging
others to do the same and so I'm hopeful
that there'll be a ripple effect from
this episode as well as it were and
really appreciate the work that you're
doing your ministry and your time for
being here as well and I appreciate the
broad perspective you've taken on this
topic thank you so much I appreciate the
opportunity
[Music]